Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Here is a question
from a viewer. Is Merrick Garland maybe just
waiting to indict everyone all at once once
the January six committee hearings are over?
Speaker 5: Hey, David. Sarah, this is Jeremy
from New Jersey. With everything that's been
going on with this errant. Dare I? With me?
Yeah. It seems obvious that Trump and some
of his associates. Have committed treason.
Yet the Department of Justice hasn't
taken action against many of these people.
And personally, I'm hoping that the DOJ is waiting
to take action. At the end of the hearings,
in the hopes that public opinion will get
turned in their favor. But I'm curious
what your thoughts are on that. Well, I.
Speaker 1: Have two thoughts. First of all,
I don't like a Department of Justice
that's making decisions on charging people
based on public opinion. They should be making
decisions and charging people based on the
evidence that they have. So in that case, I hope
that what the DOJ is doing is not waiting for
public opinion for charging these coconspirators
to be higher. That would be a bad thing. The other
piece of this is the truth is it takes a while for
the Department of Justice to put together charges.
They have to investigate. They have to decide
what what what can we prosecute, what could we
get a guilty verdict on, etc.. So it's just as
plausible that it's not that the Department of
Justice is waiting. It's that as the January
six committee exposes possible criminality,
the DOJ starts to investigate and they can take
a few months to put together what the charges
are. Now, that's optimistically thinking.
I still have seen no evidence that Merrick
Garland actually wants to or is willing to charge
anybody high level in the Trump administration
up to and including Donald Trump. I've just
seen no interest from him in doing that.
And we'll continue to follow it. I hope that that
is not the case, but I'm not feeling particularly
optimistic about it. We'll talk on the boat. His
show today about the new images from the James
Webb Space Telescope. Many of you requesting this
story super interesting. New York City monkeypox
cases have doubled again. Not good. And Jill Biden
has now apologized after saying that Latinos are
as unique as breakfast tacos. Very, very weird
thing to say. And we will talk about it on the
bonus show. Get instant access by signing
up at going Comic-Con. I will see you back.